all right so one of the biggest
challenges I faced in my career and
still continue to face till this day is
keep you up to date with all the new
things to learn about in the tech space
it almost seems like every single day
there's new AI tools being announced new
cloud services being introduced and
emerging Tech trends that are set to
transform the entire industry now as
someone who has spent two and a half
years working at AWS one of the most
fast-paced tech companies out there I
definitely felt the pressure to
constantly improve my technical skills
but over time I've been able to develop
a few strategies that have helped me
keep up to date with all of my learning
goals and so whether you're someone
trying to prepare for a certification or
learn a new programming language
self-studying is probably also something
you've struggled with as well which is
why in this video I want to share with
you the exact strategies I use to
self-study technical things these
strategies have helped me effectively
study new technical topics and I hope
they help you with your own Tech
Learning Journey let's get into it the
first strategy is what I'd like to refer
to as start broad not deep a lot of
times when we learn something new it can
be tempting to to just dive straight
into it but what I recommend doing is to
start by understanding the big picture
let's say you're studying for a cloud
certification instead of diving deep
into learning about The Individual
Services try to get a broad
understanding of the entire Cloud
ecosystem this means getting familiar
with the basics of the cloud the
different Cloud deployment models out
there and also the benefit of cloud for
companies I'd also recommend mapping out
the exact topics you need to study in
order to get the certification you can
kind of consider this stage as setting
up a learning roadmap by starting Broad
and understanding how all the different
pieces fit in together you can figure
out what to study what not to study and
how long the journey would take another
example is when you're learning AI
instead of focusing on tools like
charger BT or mid-journing you might
want to consider starting off with
learning the general concept of AI first
try to get a basic understanding of how
artificial intelligence works the key
principles behind it and the different
branches of machine learning and natural
language processing also keep in mind
that you don't have to be an expert on
every topic or technology which brings
me on to strength Energy number two
which is to learn just enough what I
mean by this is instead of trying to
learn everything there is to know focus
on what you're interested in and what
will push your career forward because at
the end of the day it's not about how
many hours you study but how many of
those hours brought you closer to your
goals for example when I worked at AWS I
had set myself a goal to become familiar
with all the key AWS services so that I
could have better conversations with the
customers I was helping to achieve this
part of what I did was obtain five AWS
certifications now even though there are
12 AWS certifications available I
stopped after completing the fifth one
this is because I noticed that I had
already gotten a good understanding of
AWS services and it's getting even more
certifications will be adding less value
to my technical skills in fact if I
spent more time getting additional AWS
certifications it would have given me
less time to do other things like build
AWS projects or making YouTube videos on
this channel and so what I learned from
that was sometimes it's better to learn
just enough rather than continuing to
learn something and get diminishing
returns now this doesn't mean you should
limit your learning and force yourself
to only learn the bare minimum instead
is to help you work smarter rather than
harder especially if you have a limited
number of hours to study every single
week once you've gotten a broad
understanding of the topic another very
important step is to get Hands-On this
means actually working with the
technology and doing something practical
let's take coding for example reading
about python or Java is one thing but
actually writing code and building a
small project gives you a lot more
insight around how the programming
language actually works it also makes
you more confident that you've actually
understood what you've learned the same
applies to other Technologies like cloud
and AI AWS Azure Google Cloud all of
these have free tiers and you can start
experimenting with the services at no
cost now while there are many ways to
gain this practical Experience One
platform I personally found very useful
is zero to Mastery zero to Mastery is an
all-in-one learning platform for you to
learn in-demand skills get hired and
Advance your career they have courses in
Cloud machine learning python and a
whole bunch of other model Technologies
or the material is kept up to date and
focuses on teaching you how to build
real world projects rather than just the
theory what I love about xero to Mastery
is that with a subscription plan you not
only get access to all of their courses
and workshops but also a community of
over 400 000 other students some of
their workshops include career-focused
topics like how to light a first take
job and how to prepare for interviews
I've been taking their complete python
developer course over the past few
months and it's been great in helping me
build my python skills so if you're
interested in trying out zero to master
3 I'll leave links in the description
below to five courses I personally
recommend checking out thank you zero to
Mastery for partnering with me on this
video another strategy that has worked
really well for me is to gamify my
learning what I mean by this is
transforming my learning process into
something that's fun and interactive
kind of like a game one example of what
I do is set up personal milestones and
weekly learning goals so while I was
learning AWS before I had set myself a
goal to understand a certain number of
AWS Services every week and to make it
more fun I treated each service like a
different level in a game so what I did
was I created a chart of all the AWS
Services I needed to master and I marked
them off as I progressed if you have
friends who are studying the same thing
as you you could even take this a step
further and create a competition for
example having a shared chart or
leaderboard where you could track how
many hours you study in a week and just
like a game the winners of the
competition could be rewarded with
something by gamifying or learning
you'll be able to make studying a lot
more fun and probably take the stress
out of having to cram lots of technical
information the fifth or final strategy
is to take good notes now there's a bit
of a debate with how effective
note-taking is some Learners swear by it
While others claim they're better off
without it everyone has their own
learning style but I want to share with
you my personal approach of taking notes
when I learned something new I like to
create one-page summaries or cheat
sheets instead of writing down every
single thing there is to know I just
document the key points because not only
does this make it easier for me to refer
back to it also takes me a lot less time
to write down all the notes and if I
ever forget the details of something I
could always Google it here's a great
example of a one-page cheat sheet you
could create for an AWS service you
could add in your own diagrams examples
as screenshots to help you break down
more complex Concepts the key is to
write down the important Concepts and
information to help you understand and
remember the topic better before we end
this video I want to share with you a
bonus mindset hack that has helped me
stay motivated when you're studying for
something and you don't feel like doing
it instead of saying I have to do this
say I get to do this remind yourself
that there are many people in the world
who don't have the privilege to
self-study maybe they're raising a large
family and have very little free time or
maybe they don't have the resources to
access the online courses you can
changing your mindset in this way can
help you appreciate the opportunity you
have to learn and grow this mindset hack
also helps you focus more on the journey
rather than the end goal like sure it's
important to set goals but sometimes we
can get so caught up in achieving the
goal that we forget to enjoy the journey
and so saying I get to do this instead
of I have to do this can act as a little
reminder for you so there you have it
five strategies I use to help me with
self-studying technical topics please
give this video a like if you found it
helpful and let me know in the comments
below which strategy was your favorite
alright bye for now